tous les jours il y avait un commando
par des régions appelé Maures Express
qui tous les jours passés entre les
baraques pour ramasser le cadavre les
fours crématoires ne sommet ni jour ni
nuit et le cycle recommençait avec
l'habillage des nouveaux arrivés à dacho
on faisait de la mort à la chaîne le 20
mars 1933 il y a 90 ans le tout premier
camp de concentration nazi ouvre ses
portes cet état d'ashow en Allemagne il
a été destiné d'abord pour les Allemands
pour ceux qui étaient contre le régime
communiste après on y habiter juifs il y
a eu tous les détails ça a été des
Espagnols
et puis après il y a des français
c'était un beau camp établi avant la
guerre pour les anti-nazies Jean laforie
un ancien résistant a connu l'enfer de
dacho la plus petite punition
c'était 25 coups de Schlag sur les
fesses il y avait des tables on a mené
le substifié on le mettait sur la table
allez baisser le pantalon et le pire
c'est qu'ont donné l'âge à un de ses
copains ça peut être le fils pour qui
tape sur le père ou le père il t'appelle
tout le fils et il fallait pas qu'il
fasse semblant de taper sans aille
recommencer éternellement Dachau théâtre
d'expérimentation médicale en tout genre
sur des détenus notamment des femmes des
atrocités filmées en 1945 à la
libération du camp attention les images
peuvent choquer
certaines d'entre elles servaient de
cobayes aux expériences des docteurs
allemands sans anesthésie bien entendu
l'une servait aux expériences de
fécondation artificielle à l'autre on
faisait en une seule semaine 5
prélèvements de moelle épinière comme
les laboratoire du diable ces
expérimentations étaient demandées par
les par le chef militaire pour le gars
qui tombait en mer jusqu'à quelle
température il pouvait durer alors on
mettait les gars dans le baimar et on
mettait de la glace on mettait de la
glace pour les pression atmosphériques
on le mettait dans un dans une dans un
sas bien fermé et on a envoyé le gaz
Jean laforie restait un an à dachaux
jusqu'au 29 avril 1945 jour de la
libération du camp par l'armée
américaine nous sommes arrivés à dachaux
par la gare justement quand ils sont
passés il y avait un train qui était
arrivé il était en stationnement
[Musique]